وتنورنا في الاستوديو في رمضان في مسائل
العربيه الفنانه الجميله ناتاش شوفان
ناتاشا نورتينا اهلا بك
معانا اليوم في مسائل العربيه شكرا كثير
مبسوطه كثير اني هون ورحييك على ادوار
التمثيليه كلها واخرها دخلت سباق الرمضاني
في سفر في دور شخصيه هنا اول شيء شو اللي
دفعك او شو اللي خلاك تقبلي تادي هذا
الدور
هنا الشخصيه بس قريت النص حبيتها كثير
لانه ذكرتني بحالي انا كتير تقرا طلب
المكتبه هاديه كتير وانا بتشبهك
مناضله لحقوق الانسان حقوق المراه
وبخبريه حلوه انا وصغيره
ماما انا كنت مدمنه بالكتب والماما كنت
تعرف هالشي فاذا مثلا ما كنت عم بدرس لاني
كنت عم بقرا كثير كانت كتب بالخزانه عليهم
كل ما اجيب علامه منيحه بتعطيني كتاب
فلما قريتها لما قريته دور هنا حسيت حالي
اوكي انه
تذكرت هالخبري انا وعم بقرا لانه دائما
محامي الكتب دائما يديها عم تكتب بالانك
حبيتها كتير لهيدا السبب اكثر شيء وحتى
يعني كمان حلو هيك بنرجع بالتاريخ لهيك
مشاهد من زمن معين
ايضا صفر برلك يعني كان موجود كتاب الناس
كانت بتقرا وككتاب على سيره الكتب لانك
بتحب الكتب كانت تقرا كتاب وروايه اليوم
هلا الترجمه بعمل درامي طب اليوم اذا بدنا
نحكي عن نتاشا او هنا في المسلسل شو اصعب
بدور او موقف او مشهد اديتيه بسفر بالي
هلا هنا بسفر بالك بنت البيك
كانت مدله هل هي مانا مدلله كشخص بس
حياتها كانت مرتاحه فانا كممثله بسفر بالك
مرتبه قد زملائي بالعمل بس انا عنجد بس
توثق بحدا ما بتوثق بحدا ما بتوثق بحدا
انا بصعوبات المشاهد والتصوير بعتقد شفت
الويلات بدكه العبيد لانه هونيك كنا عم
نصور بالطبيعه وبالوالده وبالجبل وساعات
الصبح تحت الشتاء فكانت يمكن الظروف
مختلفه مختلفه كثير بس
ظروف صعبه بس اضافه الى انه دورك كنت في
مدلله نتاشا انت مثلتي مع كوكبه من نجوم
الوطن العربي في عمل ملحمي ضخم كبير مثل
سفر بلك صور في عده مدن انتاجيه مثلا
اسطنبول مثلت المدينه المنوره صورت في
دمشق في بيروت كيف كان شعورك باختيارك في
هذا العمل كنت مبسوطه كتير العمل كان كان
ضخم وكنت مبسوطه اكون
بهيدا اللبن من بروفيشنال وهيدا وهيدا
انتاج
عن جد يعني
نحن يعني كل ما نعمل كل عمل عم تعملوا
الام بي سي عم نشوف انتاج اضخم وعندنا
نشوف قصص اكبر
القلب وتنكون كلنا مع بعض عم نشتغل على
هيك اعمال من مستوى عالي جدا اكيد ومثل
دورك نتاشا يعني انت بدك تلعبيد كبرتي
كمان بلشنا في سفر بيرلك وما بعد وين
نتاشا شو بتشوف حالها انا دايما بطلع اشوف
وين بلاقي ادوار
بحب نقي ادوار يكونوا
اكيد اسهل على المجتمع اثر ايجابي
عم نعالج
مواضيع مهمه بالمجتمع
يعني انا يعني حسب كيف منقي الدف
بنشوف لقدام يعني مررت العصف تنتقد نفسها
وتتحدى نفسها
يعني هذا مهم التمثيل الجميل في سفر وفي
دقه العبيد قبل شكرا جزيلا شكرا كثير شكرا
نتاشا شكرا لكم ثانكيو ثانكي